- Hello everyone, it
looks like we are live
and we're getting better
at starting on time.
Thanks for joining us at
our lot daily live stream
at our new time that we started yesterday
now today at 12 Pacific through Eastern
and many people are from
joining from all over the world.
We're calling this a bit of a homeroom,
because obviously in this
time of school closures
and social distancing, people can use
things like Khan Academy
at their own time and pace,
but I think we all crave
a little bit of social connection
and a way to to realize that
what we're going through,
the whole world is going through
and as as troubling is
the scenario we are in,
as a civilization there's
the silver lining is
we I think in some strange
way feel more connected
and one real you know humanity
is one group of people right now.
So just for those of you
all this is the first time
that you're attending
one of these live streams
with this home homeroom
that we do every day,
it's really a catch-all
for answering questions,
getting announcements out there.
Really just like homeroom
in real classrooms.
And it's not just for
students, it's for parents,
it's for teachers, it's for anyone else
who has questions of any form.
Just to get everyone up to speed
on what the resources
that are already out there
from Khan Academy,
obviously for over a decade
we've been building resources
that start you as early as
pre-k our Khan Academy kids app
the it's suitable for
students as young as three
all the way up through the first grade,
Common Core Standards
up through six year olds
and then on the main Khan
Academy app or website
you can for sure get
math from kindergarten
all the way through middle school,
high school and the core of college
and also sciences at
the high school level,
some humanities at the high school level
and we just launched what we call a beta,
which is almost like a pre-release
of English and language
arts for grades 2 through 8.
We also have free SAT practice
which is a partnership
with a college board that's in reading,
math and writing.
And we also have topics
like economics and others
that I mean I could I
could keep going on about.
So those resources were always all there
but as soon as we realized
that the school closure
situation was happening
a few weeks ago,
we we realized we have to step up more,
we have to provide more resources.
So that's when we started the livestreams,
we've been running teacher
and parent webinars
to help teachers and parents understand
what resources there are
and how to get started.
We have also published a schedule,
a little over a week ago
that for students of different age groups,
what could be an indicative
schedule for them,
how you can structure their day
leveraging resources from Khan Academy
and other resources including
you know dance videos
on YouTube for your PE
or you might want to go
outside and run around
or there might be some
form of reading lists.
This week some of you all realize
we just did it a couple hours ago.
We are also experimenting
with doing academic webinars.
So a few hours ago we ran our first one
which was on algebra and
we focused on the topic
of systems of equations
and we had great you know
we had a thousand students
participating and we're taking the video
and we're gonna put it
on our YouTube channel
and probably promote on
social media as well.
So you'll at least see a recording of it
and I hope many of you have a chance
to join some of these future classes.
So with that one thing I want to say
you know where we're trying to put out
all of these resources, but one question
that we're getting from
a lot of parents is,
they're just feeling a little
bit overwhelmed right now,
how do they focus on things,
you know are they doing a
disservice to their children
if if they don't have everything
all figured out just yet.
And the one thing I want to
make very clear to you is
no one has it all figured out just yet.
Even in my own house you know
I've figured out some what
for especially my older kids
but my five-year-old we're figuring it out
but it is getting day day by day better.
And so I think the important thing
to appreciate as a parent,
there's a lot of things
going on right now,
you're working from home,
a lot of people in this situation
where even they might
not be able to work now
and then you have to there's
childcare as an issue.
And so keep it simple,
especially in the first week or two
it's not the end of the world,
if things are a little
bit less structured,
if your kids if you're just having
quality time with your kids
or just whatever it takes
to get through the day.
But I think as as we go on,
try to just make sure that the kids get
a little bit of a reading every day,
a little bit of math every day.
We have suggestions obviously
Khan Academy as a resource
for both and there's reading lists
for the on the reading side of things,
you know if your kids are old enough
encourage them to journal.
And then over time you could
try to layer on more things,
try to do more and more
of the types of schedules
we've published, those schedules
are not meant to be rigid.
They are meant to be evolving documents.
We are evolving them
and you can adapt them
to your own needs.
But this session we wanna make it
as interactive as possible.
So I encourage everyone,
if you're on Facebook,
YouTube, Twitter start
putting your questions in
and we have a team of Khan Academy folks,
we're gonna be looking at them
and surfacing the questions,
it looks like a lot of
people are thinking about.
I also wanna introduce
my colleague Dan too,
who's kind of co-hosting
this livestream today
and we're gonna actually this is fun
'cause we figured out the technology
hopefully over the coming livestreams
we'll be able to bring different guests in
and people who can help out with this,
but Dan's gonna help he's
in contact with the team
that is surfacing the questions.
So please please send
send in your questions.
I'll start with one I see Stacy
Wilber from facebook says,
can you please put in an adult program
so adults can get their diplomas please.
Stacy that's one of the
dreams of Khan Academy.
We don't issue things like diplomas
but I do we do know a lot of stories
about especially adults
leveraging Khan Academy
to prepare for things like their GED
or their you know whatever graduate
requirements for high school
diplomas they might have.
So that's where we could
support you right now.
But it is a dream to one
day be able to connect
to work on Khan Academy
to you know real life
economic or academic outcomes.
And Dan feel free to jump in.
I see another question from
Facebook Shahla Karimi,
says Salaam, I have
fifth grade first grade
and something younger daughters,
why when it's a little typo,
they are all acting out
and they are really emotional
since they are home due to virus.
How can I help them?
Well shala that's a great question.
I think right now there's probably
about a billion parents
who are experiencing
some version of what you're
experiencing including myself.
So I think the first thing to realize
is don't don't beat up on yourself
and think it's just like
you're the only person
who maybe you know your
kids are acting out.
And especially you know if
they have to stay at home,
and they're not getting
as much social interaction as possible.
I'm not a child psychology expert,
I actually hope we can bring some in
into these livestreams,
all I can tell you is
try to leverage things
like video conferencing,
if you have access to it
so that they can connect
with their friends.
We've been doing playdates at home,
obviously with my youngest
who's five years old.
We've been moderating his his playdates
with some of his five-year-old friends
which can get a little chaotic
if you don't help them out a little bit,
we've been ensuring that you know
in this time of social distance
you can still take walks and
still have exercise outside,
you just have to keep
distance from other people.
But we're we're being quite religious
about making sure that we go outside
at least twice a day if we
can even if it's raining.
We're getting the umbrellas out
and saying we're going for a walk.
'Cause I think it's really
valuable to get that.
And then I think what we're
seeing in our own household
is still a little bit
interesting sometimes
but just everyone is getting
a little bit used to this new normal
which is obviously suboptimal normal,
but I think things will get better.
We've had a homeschooling
parent in the past say,
just try to stick with it,
it does get better, the
kids will get used to it.
Obviously the suboptimal
situation for everyone.
But the number one thing is
also take care of yourself.
Don't get so overwhelmed.
'Cause obviously the more as
parents we get overwhelmed
and we'll snap at our children
and then everyone will get stressed out.
So the more that you
can kind of keep calm,
whatever it does to get you know,
whatever you do in your life
to get to that meditative state,
give yourself some alone time
so that you'll have that emotional reserve
to to deal with where the kids might
the supports they might need.
Fazlu from YouTube, Faizal Kabirin
if I'm reading it correctly.
This is a crucial moment of coronavirus,
how can a student from Bangladesh
continue his studies online?
Okay, so it looks like
Fazul is from Bangladesh.
Thanks for joining us, I
think a little late there.
So you know depending
on your level of hussle,
I think the the key is
is that you actually you could view
this as a glass-half-full scenario
where a lot of the demands on your time,
especially for younger students
they might have had a
lot of social engagements
and other extracurricular
activities or homework,
a lot of those have been loosened
and so a place that Khan
Academy is a great place
to focus on those subjects
that you really wanna make sure
you have a strong foundation in,
the high school subjects,
early college subjects,
biology, chemistry, physics, economics
there's other things off-site
you know if you've graduated
outside of Khan Academy,
you can move on to things like MOOCs
and take more advanced
courses at a university level.
I think it's a great
time to take on projects
where it's one thing to learn
a lot of academic things
but can you apply it, can you create
you know can you know
create invent something
that can solve problems for folks right,
make a software application
that can do something.
So I think there's a lot of opportunities
but I think that's the best way
to be constructively occupied right now.
And obviously there might be
opportunities to volunteer
for people in your community
who might need help.
If you're a young person,
you are you should you have to
you should be still socially distanced
but you might be able to help older people
who might have trouble
leaving their houses
and have to be even more social distance
you know with things
like getting groceries,
or honestly just connecting with them.
You know keep distance and say hello
or send them a text message
or just make sure they
feel socially connected.
- Couple questions that are related.
Questions from our students
currently needing help to
schedule their study times.
So from YouTube Adnan APUs Kench Walla
as well as Sephripicin are asking
one how should they plan
their study schedule
and two if you have any tricks
to organize their time.
- So you know I don't know
what age group you're in
but one of the tricks is we
have released these schedules
that I talked about,
if you just go to Khan Academy at all
you'll see several links that say,
daily schedules you click on that.
I'm assuming y'all are maybe
high school aged students.
But there's their schedules essentially
for every age bucket high
school, middle school,
elementary school and early learners.
That's a good starting point,
there's nothing rigid about those
you can copy and paste it and
modify it to your own needs,
but what I would advise is
to have some form of a schedule
and make sure your schedule gives you time
to rest and relax.
I think you know there's two extremes
that people could fall into right now
and it's completely fine to not have
your act together in this
first or second week,
but you know there could be the extreme
where there's no structure
and you're kind of just
wandering through your days,
that doesn't feel healthy to me,
after many days or weeks of that,
you'll I think feel and a little
bit more blah so to speak.
And then the other extreme we're like
oh I got a study you know
18 hours a day and all that
and that's going that is also unhealthy.
So what I recommend is you
could use our schedules
or create your own but
schedules that cover
all the important basics,
make sure there's time for gaps
don't just try to power
through those gaps,
I think especially now we need those gaps
even more than ever and that
try to you know get front-load
the work of your day,
that's actually you know
how I try to do my life
and then by early afternoon
say okay I've done what
I need to do to the day,
I can give myself a break
and I can you know
entertain myself watch TV,
or work on a project
that I really care about,
I can do a little bit of video
conferencing with friends
and you know there's always this question
about FaceTime screen time
and I think there's good
and there's bad screen time
and actually even with sometimes
bad screen time is okay.
Now that we we're
finding more time at home
but the good screen time is
or the better screen time
is especially for an older student
is your time learning,
your time creating, writing
coding and I think it's a valuable time
to get on a videoconference zoom
or a Google meet or hangout
or Skype FaceTime with friends
and and I encourage you,
you know don't just try
to go a little bit deeper,
talk to your friends about what
what are you really thinking about,
what are they stressed about,
what are they anxious about
and remind your friends that
you're here to support them
'cause I think we all need
to hear that right now.
- Quick question for you,
it's related to our OSP product
we have a young YouTube person,
Sokina Benny, who wants to
prepare for the SAT exam
and doesn't know how to start.
- Yeah kina well that we
have a very good answer for,
for those of you who
don't know College Board
who though the folks
who administer the SAT
another nonprofit they reached out to us
about five or six years ago
and said we wanna address the
inequity around test prep,
we wanna partner with Khan Academy
to make the world's best test prep
that happens to be free.
And so we launched that
about five years ago
and it's being used by
a majority of students
who take the SAT and it's in math, reading
and actually writing as well.
You can write things to SAT
prompts and get feedback on it.
And so I think Nina was the
name if I heard correctly,
but what I encourage you to do
is go to that official free SAT practice
on Khan Academy you can
navigate on Khan Academy
or just do a web search
SAT practice Khan Academy
you'll find it and you get started
and try to spend equal
amounts of time in math,
reading, math and reading especially
and also time on writing.
What we've seen in the data
is the best practices for students are
make sure you are working on skills
that are pushing you forward
and you're not just
trying to do easy things.
Oh there you go very good.
We're getting better at this
technology all the time.
Try to peer you know
follow the recommendations.
The recommendations we
actually the software
in partnership with the SAT folks,
it knows which concepts are most important
for not just for the SAT but
also for college readiness
and also it knows where
your weak spots are.
So as you answer more and more questions,
it will know your strengths
and your weaknesses.
And so it's trying to
give you the suggestions
that are optimal for you to
learn as much as possible.
If you've taken the PSAT,
you can actually link your
PSAT scores with Khan Academy
and if you do that, your PSAT data
will inform the software even more
what your strengths and weaknesses are.
So I would go there and I know we have,
you know the next SCT
administration got canceled
but it will come back
I am sure at some point
and so I think this is a great opportunity
to spend some time every day.
We even have it in some of our schedules,
even if you're able to put
30 or 40 minutes a day that's great.
And I would say at least once a week
try to take a full-length practice test.
We're seeing that is also a best practice
that helps a lot of students.
And when you take that practice test,
try to take it in as most
realistic circumstances as you can
so yes, spend some time on
our official SAT practice.
Let's see you have a
question from Debby Charlton,
says thank you for all you have been doing
to help teachers to use
Khan more during this time
as an ambassador I've been
doing conference calls
to help teachers get
set up and move forward,
the items created have
been a huge help to many.
Oh well thanks Debbie for that comment.
For those of you know,
Debbie is a one of our
teacher ambassadors.
We have a thousand
teachers around the world
who are super users of Khan Academy
and our super teachers.
And they've been incredible mentors
for other teachers and other folks
to help them get started on Khan Academy
and thinking about how they can integrate
Khan Academy to their
instructional practice
and especially in a time like this.
How they can integrate Khan Academy
into you know their
virtualization plan so to speak.
So thank you Debbie for
being an ambassador.
We really appreciate that.
You know a lot of what we do
is informed by the teachers
on our Bachelor community.
Because we're trying we want to make sure
we have as much support
for teachers as possible.
- So Sal our next question
is fun from YouTube
by Prag Yamaha, her question is
hello how is it important to make notes
each time we watch a video?
- I think notes can be valuable.
I think the most important
thing when you watch a video
is to try to do it in an active way.
So if the video is about to
go through a worked example,
pause the video, try to solve it
at least attempt it yourself.
If the video is about to explain
the stages of mitosis for
example if in your biology,
try to think about it yourself.
Say okay do what do I know about it,
what do I don't know about it.
So you get your brain primed.
Then on top of that I think it is useful
for a lot of folks to take notes.
It helps kind of multiple
modalities to do that.
You know but for other people
it might be more useful
to just really make sure
they're focused on what's being said.
I think sometimes notes can kind of be
kind of a blind process too.
So the more that you can take notes
but when you take the notes,
you're really processing.
So you're not just writing verbatim
or drawing verbatim.
You're looking at what's happening
and this is true whether
it's a video or a classroom.
You're like okay now let me process that
and digest it in my own words,
I think that could be a lot more valuable.
The important thing is
to really pay attention
and the beauty of videos
is you can pause it
and say okay do I really get that,
how would I do it etc.
And then you can you can play
and see how the the Video Creator
has approached the concept.
- So on Facebook so we have RIA Bhatia
who's asking will Khan
Academy be putting up
AP Computer Science a courses.
- The AP Computer Science, so
we we have AP CS principles
that we already have it's
you're probably aware of it.
We don't have AP Computer Science a yet
you know what I've told folks is
we're trying to add subjects
as quickly as possible,
functionality as quickly as possible
but we are not for profit
that is philanthropically supported
and what a lot of folks
my wife was telling me last night
she's like Sal I don't
think people realize
that Khan Academy is
philanthropically supported,
Khan Academy is a large team
that that you know and
even just our server cost.
So what I would say we want
to be able to serve that
but we're gonna need a
little bit more resources
and I'm not asking it from you Ria.
But I'm asking it from everyone listening.
The more support we have the
more bandwidth we will have,
literally and figuratively
to be able to create more courses.
But I hope that over time we can fill out
more and more of these courses.
But AP CS principles is
definitely a great place
to start if you haven't done so already
and also our programming platform
is a great way to learn.
It starts quite simple, it could be used
by an elementary school student
to kind of draw and make some animations,
but you can do some very
sophisticated things
and things like
object-oriented programming
and simulations you can go quite deep
on our computer programming
platform as well.
- So Sal we have a question about AP exams
with the changes and
how the exams gonna be
administered on YouTube of to cebra
asks should we study any differently
for the AP exams now that there
are 45 minutes and online?
- What you know I I would still,
let's see the way I would approach it is
and on if if it's an AP exam
that Khan Academy materials for
and we have chemistry, biology,
physics, microeconomics,
macroeconomics, government and politics,
American history, CS principles
and obviously calculus and stats,
if it's one of those I would still try
to get mastery on Khan Academy,
you know a week or two before the AP exam
is as far as you can get.
And then a week or two before the exam,
I would look at old sample
free response questions
and try to do as many
of those as possible.
We have worked examples of
many of those on Khan Academy
and many of those subjects
and so there I would give the same advice
that I've gave earlier as
when the problem is presented,
pause it, try to solve it yourself
and then see how I or someone else
might have worked through that problem.
But I think if you do that
combination mastery on Khan Academy
and then you have a week or two
of really doing having a lot of experience
with the free response questions
and there's banks of
those questions online.
Some of them and have solutions,
I think you're gonna be very well prepared
for I guess you know this new modality
that we might be seeing in a
couple of in about a month.
- And so I would add to that,
um Adam on our content team and I
are working on how to
put together a quick,
how to study for this,
based on the new information we have.
So that's a resource
we're gonna try to get up
hopefully next week to the students.
- Yeah and I don't want to jump the gun
but you know I mentioned earlier
that you know we're exploring ways
to do academic webinars,
we just did one in algebra earlier
and so as we get closer to AP's
I hope that we we might be able
to explore some things there,
maybe do some office hours
and things like that.
So let's see on Facebook Kristen Martinez,
their way to sign course challenges
to students as a teacher.
And I'll let the Khan Academy team
confirm what what I'm about to say
because I know some of
the stuff is in flux.
You can assign obviously specific skills
on Khan Academy as a teacher
and parents can do this too.
You can essentially may
become your students coach
by if they say add coach
and enter your coach ID
and there's resources that
explain how to do that.
But you can make assignments
of specific skills
for specific videos,
you can make assignments
on unit tests, you can make
assignments for course mastery
so you could say hey I would
like you to get 100% mastered
in biology by May 2nd, so you can do that
and I believe you can assign course,
it's definitely on our roadmap.
I don't know a Dan or
someone from the team
can we confirm that we can
whether we can assign course challenges?
Well I'll wait for those those answers
once we once we can get confirmation.
But I do think course
challenges are a great way
and I mean at minimum you could assign it
through something like an LMS
you know you can put a link
to the course challenge.
But I do think they're
a great place to start
especially if students already
knows some of the material
and to understand where
you are in the course
and they're also a great way you know
as the question about AP tests,
as you get closer and
closer to the AP test,
I would take more and more
course challenges as well.
'Cause that makes sure that
you are able to understand
what concept is applicable
for a given item
without knowing what
skill is from or what unit
and they're all mixed up.
So I would take course challenges
and I do a lot of free
response for the AP students
to kind of prepare is it get closer.
- Yeah so Sal just an update on that one.
Currently you cannot
assign course challenges
or spy review and course
mastery unfortunately.
- Yeah you can't assign course mastery,
you can't assign spiral view
and yeah the spiral view
these distinct some mastery challenges
and those just show up
and then the course challenges
you could just send a
link to your students
for them to get started on that.
But yeah unfortunately
don't have that yet,
you know all of the other assignment
functionality that comes with it.
- Alright so we have a
question from Facebook Chris.
Sorry um from Butarif Mohammed.
So how can I be a part of
Khan Academy an educator?
- Well I think they you know
we always have job postings out
so look at those but I think you know
in a general sense you know we are always
trying to connect with amazing educators.
So you should join our Facebook page,
our Facebook group for
teachers called teach with Khan
and that you know obviously
stay involved in things like this,
I'm exploring other, we're
exploring other projects
on how we might be able to
leverage teacher volunteers
to help more students especially
in this time of school closures.
So we will be sure to keep people posted
on all of the above, alright.
So I could let's see ask
another question here.
Someone said I added an
hour to your daily schedule
for creative time where
my kids have to create
rather than consume
their sewing doodling learning to juggle,
any other ideas for kids
on what they can create?
So I that's a great idea that you added
that creative time you know in our V
and our first version of the schedules,
it was kind of implied
that could happen in the
afternoons or the evening
but that's cool to kind
of put it in the middle.
I do think for creative time
depending on what they're doing,
it is nice to have large blocks of time.
So 'cause you know you it just
takes sometimes half an hour
just to get set up and then you might want
two, three hours to really create.
So encouraging people
either do in the afternoon
or you can modify the schedule like that.
So beyond sewing doodling
learning to juggle
I think there is there's a lot
you know drawing is great
there's people on YouTube
who have these drawing tutorials,
you can ask them you know you can
storytelling is really incredible,
you can ask kids to come up
with a you know alternative
reality of what's going on
or you know what would
the world might look like
after through this crisis
or yeah there's just a lot
of fun writing activities,
we've talked a little bit about coding
and this you know this
is a great opportunity
for students to start
exploring engineering things,
coding, making inventions.
I think social service can be creative.
You know what can especially kids do
for their community right now
I think this is actually a moment
where kids can step up
to serve the elderly
especially with maybe
helping them get groceries
or just giving them a source of connection
in this in this time of social distancing.
That can happen virtually
or maybe just you know
waving to your your neighbor
or you know across the
street and things like that.
So I think there's a lot of
you know you can make videos,
you can make kind of
Khan Academy style videos
explain things to your friends,
you can you know actually
I played on the weekend
it was my family and another family,
we played this this this
game called Pathfinder
it's kind of a new version
of Dungeons and Dragons.
But that was it's very creative.
You go through these adventures together.
So I think there's all
sorts of creative things
that you can obviously
you know you can paint,
you can dance, you can choreograph,
there's there's a lot
that can that can happen.
- So in closing just one
more question from Facebook,
Josh Carroll asks, are there ways
to perhaps help parents teach math
in ways that show the applied side,
say show how to apply quadratic functions
to things like parabolic machine?
- Yeah I mean for that particular example,
if kids are curious you could actually
start going into the physics
which we have on Khan Academy
and if the students
already know quadratics
and actually if they even know just
the basics of trigonometry which hopefully
they got from some of
their geometry classes.
But you could even go over that with them.
They're ready to go into
things like projectile motion,
two-dimensional projectile motion.
And you know one-dimensional
projectile motion,
you actually don't need any trigonometry
you just need to know a
little bit about quadratics
and so that's a very
interesting application.
You can actually see how
good your predictions hold up
or you can use the math to
understand and go outside,
use a timer throw a ball in the air,
figure out how long it's in the air
and then based on that you can figure out
how high it went, which is kind of cool.
You can figure out how high a ball went
by timing it and then you could say
well how exact is it,
because in our equations we
didn't have air resistance,
now we do and things like that.
But I think that's actually a lot of fun.
And then obviously you
can do the same thing
with two dimensions.
You can figure out the angle
by maybe where it lands
or how far it went based
on measuring you know
there's all sorts of interesting things
you could do with that.
So physics is a great place
to apply that type of thing.
You'll see a lot of that
in economics as well,
and a lot of the basic algebra
actually you'll see in
in chemistry as well
and actually some of the
genetic stuff in biology.
So I think those are
all really interesting.
They obviously exponential growth.
(laughing)
It's not hard to find videos
and we put a few on exponential growth
and how viruses spread
and how you can convert two days doubling
to what the factor is
it's being multiplied
over any time period
and exponential growth.
So I think you know if if
there's a silver lining here,
everyone should get out of this crisis
learning about exponentiation.
And how to manipulate it and
what its implications are.
So on that maybe not
so uplifting note huh.
I just want to thank everyone thanks Dan
for helping me out, thanks
for the entire team,
thanks for everyone who's joining,
we have some of these quick testimonials,
Schatzi Cunningham from Facebook
says my hope my homes loves Khan Academy,
we love you too.
We are actual home schoolers
and we are subscribed
because you break things down clearly
so the youngest could even understand.
Well appreciate that Schatzi,
but you know we love feedback
positive or negative,
we're always trying to get better.
And then you from YouTube,
we have Cory Geisler says
thank you for all you do Sal
and I want to be clear
it's much more than me,
Khan Academy is a team of over 200 people
and we have thousands of
volunteers around the world.
You have helped me all year long,
it's not easy going back
to college at 42 years old,
so thank you for all you do.
Well Cory we're about the same age
and yeah I could imagine you know
I have dreams every now that
I'm going back to college
but I could understand.
(laughing)
But I'm a happy we kid we can support you
and I applaud you for going back
and always learning.
I think that's the biggest skill
of just continuous learning.
So you know thanks everyone in joining,
this is a great way to connect,
I feel more connected to you.
I hope we all feel more
connected to each other.
All of humanity is going
through this together
and I'm very confident we're
going to get through this
and as we're going through this,
hopefully we build some empathy
and ways to connect with each other
that we can carry on once
we get to some normalcy.
And I will remind everyone,
we are not-for-profit,
we are funded by a
philanthropic donations.
I wanna thank some corporations
that have really stepped up recently
like Bank for America, 18 T
Google org and Novartis now
to help support our
response to the crisis,
our server costs are going to be 2/3 x
of what they normally will be
so with millions of dollars,
but we still need more help.
We're still running at
a significant deficit.
It's not clear how long
we can run like this.
So we need help we need
donations from everyone,
even a two to three dollar donation
and these things add up
so that we can keep doing
the Duke work we do,
we can keep the site performant,
we can keep serving folks
who might not be in the position to donate
and make sure we can
support the billion of kids
around the world who are out of school
and the 50 million kids
in the United States
who are out of school.
So thank you so much for joining
and I will see you tomorrow.